[Applause]
by this axe
i ruled
[Music]
welcome
to another exciting episode of kos
and who
is this handsome
devil
that i have
to my right
well it's none other than
scishow's collectibles
dolph mall
bust
um
what can i say golf mall is probably the
single
uh greatest reason why uh i'm a super
star wars fan i've always watched star
wars i've always been a fan of star wars
and before that it was boba fett
but
when i saw the trailer for the phantom
menace
um
it took my fandom
to another level it took it straight out
of the stratosphere and um
i saw a character that i was super
intrigued with
double lightsaber or the like
when he light up both ends of the
lightsaber
it blew my mind um the trailer showed
that he was athletic the fight scenes
looked more intense
um
absolutely
incredible
viewing
of
how i felt
uh a star wars movie should be i saw
when i saw it i absolutely lose my lost
my mind
needed to go see it i was super
anticipating it and uh from the minute
that i got there i knew
that um this was my new favorite
character
um
i honestly think
this is the time that you guys need to
take a room tour with me i'm not a
complete room tour
more of uh
come
hang out with me
in the red room as we talk a little
darth maul
let's go
ah
this feels a whole lot better
so now that you're getting a chance to
see me in the red room
and when the lights go off
in this room it is truly the red room
y'all get to see that on the preview
but again
this is my mole bust
this is my wall of mall
as you can see
i have xm studios mall i have multiple
sideshow uh
premium format malls and i have the
mythos
malls
uh got the moles that matter to me
that fit my wall
but i needed this bus
in order
to complete what i say is my collection
what's crazy is
today
i got in
another mall
print
officially darth maul print
i'm also going to show you uh
the picture
that i have up here of golf mall
beautiful stuff
but um
this character uh changed how i viewed
the star wars uh
landscape
when i saw
the movie trailer
for phantom menace
and it showed dolph maul you know hop
out he was doing
all these wonderful moves with a
lifesaver
it took it away from the older movies
where they were stiff and kind of
robotic with the lifesavers yeah the
lifesavers were uh
dynamic within itself but
to me darth maul
brought a new aspect of of what
lightsaber battles could be
uh
the little known fact is
ray parker dream the the charac the guy
who plays dolph maul
only had three speaking lines
and
three speaking words i believe and only
six minutes of screen time
six minutes of screen time this guy has
impacted me to the point where
uh he was indispensable for me as far as
the universe goes i want to give a shout
out to
my legion of doom brother the host
of legion of doom thor
aka darth vader
um he put me on to the fact that dolph
maul didn't die at the end of that in
that movie darth maul was killed he was
cutting half by obi kenobi
can't stand obi-wan kenobi
and um
obi-wan kenobi you know
after he killed uh obi-wan's uh
master
dolph maul did and then obi-wan you know
kind of tricked him and killed him
though uh vader explained to me that
he was never
like darth vader where he can be
a master
he's a an assassin
okay so there's different levels of
the way the sith move
so darth maul was never going to be a
master he did take on an apprentice
i'm going to tell you that in a second
but
after he got cut off and i was like wow
man the greatest character
in in in star wars history and that's it
so i get on the show uh
dc dcx
and dog um vader explains to me that
there's more to darth maul
uh he actually has a whole story if i
looked at rebels i never looked at
rebels because it was a cartoon i really
didn't care for that but my son and my
daughters watched it so so i went back
excuse me and i watched it the episodes
were darth maul then i found out he had
a brother called savage oppressed and
and they took him back and he got his
mind right uh
and
it's crazy for a long time because if
you look at one of those
um
pieces down there
he has chicken legs we call it chicken
legs because they gave him robotic legs
until he became whole later
and in before then
he had this big spider legs
um
they kind of messed me up kind of made
me upset but listen so i watched rebels
and they fleshed out darth maul's story
i found out he's from dolph mayor and
all this stuff and i found out more
about the character he had so much more
screen time he was so much more in depth
about the actual character that endeared
me more to the character besides the
double lightsabers besides the the movie
six minutes that i got of him
it showed me that this character had
depth
and then
at the end of his run at the end of his
storyline
he dies again from obi-wan kenobi
this time on a straight up one-on-one
piss me the hell off death to obi-wan
kenobi don't care about him as a
character
you know seth for life
i know you like that vader um
but darth maul is
a very huge part of my movie going
experience of how i feel about the star
wars universe
um
[Music]
this piece
is invaluable you can do it with the
hoodie on
or the hoodie off
you know and he has the earring
that ray parker jr had on
uh
during filming
yeah i forgot it one day they just left
it in there so it became part of the
statue statue is beautiful
the bus is beautiful i only have two bus
one was a mistake and this one is on
purpose
uh so you know shout out to the one
that's on purpose uh fantastic piece
uh the rest of these pieces are
incredible i'm going to do individually
each by each one
and i'm going to show you how the
lightsabers light up for those that do
have light up lifesavers and um
lightsabers
and the ones that don't i'm just going
to show you in the totality
these are dynamic pieces the xm piece
shout out to my man mojo he just got his
uh is one of the best
if not the best mall piece ever made
all right there's a lot of people that
want to say some of the mythos down
there like vader would say but honestly
in my opinion that one him jumping off
of his bike like he did in the movie and
they caught him in that action scene
utterly incredible
well this is the time in the video when
i'm gonna ask you to like follow and
subscribe
and hit the joy button hit that joy
button you heard that join button and i
got to work on my join button music
again because i'm kind of messing up but
you guys hit that join button it's right
there at the bottom join the realm so
you can see more kos when it does pop up
go to watch uh the last word with lol
cognito and ivantas please tune into the
attic show the attic show has a ton of
stuff going on here's a ton of guests
going on there and it's a little bit
something different
my boy lord attic works on it very hard
so go check that out also we do r r with
the lords if you're a patreon member you
can check that stuff out early that
stuff is behind the scenes you can see
what goes on with the lord so join the
realm or become a patreon member go back
there to watch and see what iron lords
podcast does remember football season is
about to start and we're back at 11 00
a.m eastern standard time this kind of
sucks i can't stand it but go to the
lords of gaming.net where all the stuff
that i just told you is
and this statue with all the dimensions
price and stuff like that
is on the website i don't go into
uh dimensions i don't pull out a scale
and
listen i have a website for that you
want to know all of that stuff go to the
website i'm not going to borrow you with
boring tedious stuff i'm just going to
give you why i got the statue why i love
the statue and why it's in my collection
and if you maybe like it maybe you can
go get it as well
but listen tune in next week when um
i'm going to start bringing you content
on a scale that is really ridiculous
because you guys are going to get a
chance to see the red room in its
totality
with the lights off so you can see what
the boom boom room really do
next week i'm going to give you
another red character from the red room
somebody mentioned it and i thought i
did that kos and realized that i didn't
so
stay
collected
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
by
i rule
[Music]
you